[Musique]
jeune et brillant mon est vraiment
servir les gens
[Musique]
les petits les graves je suis belge fait
du mec au fric je fais dit wak oo
la legge fait des libres 2 au total
esprit du work l'a fait sans les
responsabilités la flemme donc je fais
de la quantité sa peine quand dans les
médias aux portes de moi on me dire
combien je gagne dans moins d'un an et
je voudrais la crtv c
ta mère
je m'explique mon taf mammeri tories
benja terry fait du budget des trucs
débiles merci les conventions dans les
faits
l'addiction face aux chiffres qui
défilent quel plaisir d'être enfin de
vraies
[Musique]
moi pas
m
c'est ma
ma
jeune et brillant monde est vraiment
j'aspire les gens les petits les grands
enjeux fui ma famille la fashion je
montre mes habits la critique tu changes
d'avis aux riches donc blog mal et mes
amis sont des concurrents bien sûr je
vais pas durer dans le temps je veux
plaire aux parents plaît aux enfants
jetés sur twitter ce que j'en pense
c'est mon vote si t'as plus d'abord dit
moi je suis moche comme les abdos
s'acquitte donc je raconte les ragots je
veux savoir qui influence les jours
[Musique]
lancée
mais moi pas
[Musique]
là
forest
efforts
m
s'ils avaient vraiment de feu comme un
sauveur font de la pub même se dorait
que le maire sam un chat - ne change pas
de neige on se croit la foulée
[Musique]
heures